all right pepper
yes sir pepper oh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally i'm from
iowa i'm born and raised the names iowa
boone county
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were a kid
i know of my mother real well because
i'm
like her my mother's straight up hippie
my mother married a klan member
my dad's the head of one of the clans
out there
so at the age 12 he got he was racing
stock i got an axe damn flipped off in
the grass dance killed two kids and got
herself in body cast
my dad come to me it's like son you have
hulk clan meeting that you're only boy
you got nine sisters
and quickly i invented myself i'm like
i'm not part of this i'm a flower child
1966 july 9th
i do not believe in your clan ways your
clan
[ __ ] don't force it on me
it's not of my realm i'm a flower child
piece of love
pop some pills get high let's make love
my dad got angry said you're not my son
i said you're not my dad
my dad wouldn't be a coward behind the
sheep burning in burning
alive animal [ __ ] representing people my
dad would not be hateful
towards everyone so you see i
come from a family that's really torn
apart by
hatred at the age 14 i
left guy told my mother mom i need to
get up out of
[ __ ] me this man's at the same table
eating i'm sitting with the butcher
knife in my hand
with the fork saying god i wish you'd
say something to me
i'm so sick of your [ __ ]
so days 14 i got my first car working i
was working at her metal slaughter house
the youngest worker there but my friend
owned it and i told him i need to leave
soon i
can't live in this house with this
hatred
this guy so when i hit 14 i
i got my nova
and i really didn't want to leave my mom
behind
like mom get in the car let's go it's
like i can't
he'll come looking like last time and
beat me again
like mom how are you how many beating
you i take every week
for nothing when he gets drunk he just
speaks on me
so you see i was forced to to inventory
myself
at a young age what do i really want in
life
what am i who am i
and and you know what all my life i've
been searching for one thing
and i know i'll never find it
father and son relationship like the
rest of people
something i i don't have i mean i can
have all the money in the world
but can i buy true love from my dad or
something
no you can't so you see
i packed up my bags i saved up like 2
300
i've been stocking on chevron gas cards
i knew i had to leave home i couldn't
deal with the snowman
my mother begged let me give you all my
life savings
make sure you're safe when you don't
come back home i'm like
i'm not i'm not as long as he's alive
i'm not
i'm not part of this you cannot force
that it's a shoe that don't fit
don't you understand i'm a flower child
i'm all breed of the hippies the next
generation of hippies is
us i need to live my life and make
something of me
i swore to myself from from
a young age i'd never be like my dad
well i don't know how my dad had it
happened or what i don't know the issues
nothing i know he had some gun play
he got half a finger it's a stubby
but it's half
well when i was working at home out
i had an accident when the saw bands
broke
and flew up and i had time go like this
i amputated tip of my finger
i'm like damn it damn it mom look
i'm like my dad i told you i didn't want
to stay here she's like
no baby you lost the tip of your finger
your dad has half a nub
like mom it's an homie i gotta go i
gotta go
that was part of it my hands started
looking like my dad's hands
and my mother swore up and down baby you
stood out i gave your whole finger this
tip of your finger was cut off i'm like
mom it's still a stubby
it's so stubby like no your dad ain't
got no fingers now
you got a messed up horse like a finger
now but you got a finger now
it's not a stubby mom did everything she
could
like i say mom tried to give me all her
life savings i told her no
i mean i got 21 chevron cards
with 160 dollars of gas on them
got like 14 000 in my pocket
i'm late i can't do this no one
my mom packed me a backpack
and i called her a week on the road i
found
well over over half a million dollars
involved my backpack
she did it her money she did it she gave
me her savings
like you're my only boy i got nine girls
what am i supposed to do like mom i told
you don't
i'm a man man meant to survive or live
off the land
it was all good
well that year christmas
i got him with a girlfriend a
full-blooded black foot indian girl
for seven long years i lived in arkansas
on the black foot reservation
the best years of my life crying no [ __ ]
till i came
to to the wilderness i know what plants
to eat
i know what plants to make medicine it
was the
time of my life because i learned so
much from that from from that woman
when i got a little older 21 i married
that woman
you know i had a baby maria
my dad's still alive i still don't go i
still don't
talk about him i have no father
i have no father that i want to mention
be i got a father but i don't see the
evil realm
okay i've blocked that off
mentally physically you gotta gotta make
a choice in life
what you gonna be what's gonna do
i am a flower child
and that's for sure you know
then i come to california
and i got involved in the revolving
doors
i came out here selling chris crystal
our
angel dust andrew dust
went to me using crystal from crystal
and snorting
coke in and out county jail
for some time i'm 54 now
i'm like [ __ ] christmas day again
now i'm sitting in [ __ ] county jail
what's wrong with me
why can't i seem to make it on these
streets
well i got my uh
seventh prop 36
just couldn't get out of dope scene
they get added up to like 10 12 years
probation
but they kept getting kicked down kicked
down
but his timing is getting me is getting
more and more quantity
i was drinking successfully
so the judge said i'm gonna make you a
deal that's your 11th
prop 36. i'm going to send you
to a year of rehab
i said good i'll be leaving here at
kansas city
i'd already had it planned and [ __ ] i'm
going to take off from the gate
sorry i already knew what i was going to
do
something happened when i got to that
rehab
the first week
my birth certificate come to me i'm like
what am i iowa
i'm a country [ __ ] oh my god
then the girl girl come
tested i got my first negative test
for alcohol and drugs
but about a week later on my birthday
i'm celebrating my birthday
here i am giving a 4g touchscreen phones
i
told all my friends and stuff they will
say i'm so proud of you
then a few few days later my california
id come i'm like
i never had california you never had no
id at all
so you see stuff happened in that rehab
spontaneously week after week
i started learning more and more about
me
i started getting my id my social
security card came
my birthday came i finally knew who i
was
then i got my third negative
drug and alcohol test
i'm like you know what i'm leaving every
weekend on
pass i'm coming downtown i got my bmx
bike i'm hitting the half pikes
at the skateboard thing
i got a way but all this time
at rehab and compton ms ward said i
don't care what you do you
leave you can run away every day but as
long as you live here
every sunday at nine o'clock you'll be
in church
that's all i ask you [ __ ] what you do
where you go don't give me a dirty
and don't miss a day church so you see i
started to uh
known the lord so i started looking at
stuff
differently i started feeling good about
me
okay and that's what kept me drinking
you
dope i thought nobody give a [ __ ] i
wasn't
needed and ain't nobody give a [ __ ]
about homeless
i was wrong there are people who give a
[ __ ]
they are people that hurt seeing seen us
like this
yeah i'm still on the street after 40
years now
it's not because anyone else is because
of me
i have an authority problem although i'm
drug free
sober free and i do work with the lord
now
i started accomplishing stuff on the
internet
i got my first music video
ever last long at all on youtube
i did that when i was 46. i've held
number one spot
this long time 54. okay
you you were in motorcycle gangs too
right off and on yes
yeah i mean the motorcycle gang was good
it was a family it was a brotherhood
but i wasn't in it because
i needed the gang i wanted the gang
like i said i searched for love for like
a father figure
okay well now i know my real father
father who are in heaven okay
that's my real father he's the one that
wakes me up every morning every day
so the next thing a few months later i
get google
sciences la stories on google
well three three and a half weeks though
i got
l.a originals on netflix
once i stopped drinking totally with the
help that rehab
will help me get my id knowing who i am
fighting myself
i was able to stop those revolving doors
i had been in jail the prisoner got
ticketed in six years now
almost six and a half but the whole time
i'm i'm a church goer
you ever heard of city limits on glass
park
sixth and gladys
i have i know my real father
i i'm a christian that does the work of
the lord
okay the lord gave me a way out
i got to know my father i know him to
this day
everyone in life goes through phases
okay
everyone in life goes through love loss
of family members and stuff
but if you ever had go through the
hatred that i went through
i wish there are no person no child
okay and i'm just gonna end
like this remember
everyone is needed everyone is special
and everyone
has the real fathers to then come to
you know i went through pure hell i've
made it this far
only because the father went before me
and cleared my path
as a wreckage the father is with me
and he comes after me because i make
mistakes too
i'm well known out here half the
internet's me
but this success costs
costs a great deal you must inventory
yourself
for yourself you must go deep within
and see what really makes your roots
stay attached
you've got a choice to make your life
it's not going you think i wanted to
leave my mother and my
my ranch at age 14. and hit the streets
i was forced out of my home
i was forced by a greater force than i
could control
and i knew that
i made the choice to take it to the
streets
this is my comfort zone the media does
its best to get it smashed so we're so
[ __ ] up and relentless and renegades
not true we're people like you
like him like me people surviving
the only way we know how just just to be
thankful this is my comfort zone the
street
this is where i can be me
i don't judge people i give everyone the
same
love unconditional unconstitutional love
i don't need
to know you'd say hey god bless you have
a good day
i don't need to know you hey you're
hungry you need to buy
water i'm not a rich rich man
but in some aspects i'm richer than most
i have a heart that loves and knowledge
that's
out of this world but that knowledge
come by leaving home
well you see the thing about me
i'm fighting a few a few issues
not only the racism issue
but i'm a hiv carrier
okay now just because i'm hiv carrier
don't mean my life is over when the
doctor
told me pepper we tested your blood
you have hiv but don't worry
you're not dying i said you're damn
right i'm not
now i make my mark
that's another reason why i'd start
taking to the air
i have a dream you know marilyn monroe
kind of burned out long for her legend
ever will
i have a message for the younger stuff
no matter what you're fighting in life
whether it be
inside or outside your immune system
don't give up if you just tested hiv
positive
don't give up there's one third people
that's a carrier
like me i carry i've been infected
don't know how i don't shoot up i don't
mess around
but it's not
what people think it is okay
you could change any any sickness you
got
like convenient 19.
your diet plays a lot in in your
health system okay
so i tested hiv positive i'm a carrier
i'm losing weight
okay so put yourself on a high cal pro
diet
you consume a thousand calories a day
your body needs that to burn up so you
stay the same size you are
a hiv carrier has to eat twice as much
as a person that's healthy
to keep our immune system up and
fighting
a lot of people don't tell you that you
see this is one of the messages that ace
i want to give you young people out
there
we can beat this to be 19. we can beat
hiv
with loving one another the best thing i
can tell you is
to love one another like it's the last
supper
because it just might be
you